i want to talk about how many incredible
legends are a part of this cast
i'm sure the two of you were totally
excited to meet everybody i was that was
part of the cast
but be real with me who are you most
geeked out over
daphne
[Music]
[Applause]
the icon that i i was obsessed i've been
obsessed with rent
it's one of my favorite musicals so like
getting to meet her and then hear her
voice her such a she has such a unique
and iconic voice
she's also the sweetest human
ever and so oblivious to the fact that
she's
an icon that inspired so many latinas to
go into musical theater because of
because mimi existed
yeah and and she's just incredible i i
i know when i saw her during during our
last audition day in new york leslie
where we met
i think y'all left and i just stayed
here hanging around because they were
they were changing me roles they were
like what do we do with her
and daphne walks in and i'm like
i was like do i do i go up to her do i
tell her and i just went like
she was like i think she had her
headphones on and i just like tapped her
on the shoulder and i was like
i love you yeah go back to what you're
doing
daphne it's just like the most
oh it's just the sweetest human it's a
love fest every time you're around
daphne
um and to see her play this woman
for specifically for me to see her play
a woman that feels like my mother you
know like
you know she she's elba yeah yeah she's
a salon
salon lady and have them meet was like a
full circle moment
um because i felt like daphne was my
mama on set she's a woman that i feel
like man if i would have seen you on
screen
more i would have felt so validated as a
as a afro-latina young girl you know so
um for them to meet was really cool and
mark anthony
but i can't i could just listen to did i
see anyway
listen everybody wanted everybody was
beat that he was going to be on set and
i just have to say like we were in the
middle
of like you know it's the heights we're
in a little um
hallway you know leading up to this tiny
apartment
and all of the crew is lined up in the
hallway one
elevator no ac in that hallway it was
corey it was
uh gregory it was me it was you know
anthony obviously is in the scene
and we're all just stuck glued to that
playback like yo look at mark anthony go
look at marketing
look at who's looking right look at and
it was just it was school
man those five we keep saying those five
minutes were oscar worthy
i feel like there's something in the
water with this cast i see you doing
photo shoots together
i see you hanging out at john m chu's
house together
what is it specifically about the
friendships that were formed
with the in the heist cast it's the love
yeah a real love it's a real love that
we feel for each other that we were
these these character always says these
characters have history you know they
know each other they're their chosen
family their
their um their own community that
they've built on the block that
have seen each other grow and are
rooting each other on and when you put
people like that um in the same room the
love is inevitable
you know what i mean it was a
life-changing experience for all of us i
think and i think when you have a
life-changing experience
it binds you together forever and i
think that
we we will always have that summer in
new york
and now we're stuck with each other for
life
it's impressive to land any role in any
movie
and then there's landing a role in in
the heights where you must be
a triple threat if you had to pick one
which was the most challenging was it
the acting
was it the singing or was it the dancing
the dancing you already know was the
dancing
i did not expect the movie to have
as much dancing as there is because i
think that
the actual characters dance a lot more
in the movie than in the
in the play and there wasn't a dance
portion of the audition so i remember
showing up day one and we're rehearsing
champagne
why not and it is completely
choreographed
every single movement is choreographed
and anthony and i just looked at each
other like the dancing was the hardest
part
for sure for all of us in the club come
on
[Applause]
were there busted feet were there hired
soaks at the end of the day how grueling
was it
all of us had busted feet i remember mel
soaking her feet in ice buckets every
night because
she was dancing and he was prepping her
feet
[Music]
[Applause]
i think this movie ends so beautifully
poised
for what could be a phenomenal sequel
are there discussions about getting the
group back together
and doing another in the heights hi
i i already started the petition yeah
yes
there is nothing that we would want more
world even if it takes lynn another 20
years to write the sequel we will
come back
everybody you know like i think that
there was nothing that we would love
more but we know
writing a musical is not an easy thing
to do
so it really all depends on lin and
kiara yeah yeah
if one day you wake up and wake up and
they're like i dreamed up the sequel
and lynn is like inspired and writes the
songs i mean
we're we're there listen it's lemon well
miranda i do not doubt that he
can do that we'll be here when that
moment
the flight to happens couple of days
you